bang
bang what's up guys welcome back
to lunch money i'm here with the
beautiful and intelligent playing the e
by love of marinova poppliano p-i-m-p
what up we're doing this even at the
risk of missing our flight we're getting
lunch money out
facts dedication what's up uh lunch
money is now sponsored by block five do
not forget go
sign up for a block by account block
five dot com
you can earn up to 8.6 interest in an
interest bearing account
it's awesome i'm an investor i sit on
the board i'm a big
fan you will be too go get an account
get money get paid go get a block
by account blockfit.com 8.6
apy and an interest bearing a count
what's up let's go we're going to rattle
through this stuff 12
minutes before i get yelled at jp morgan
chase ceo jamie dimon expressed
confidence tuesday and america's ability
to get through next month's election
even as he urged the federal government
to do more to prevent a double dip
recession i have great faith in this
country and i'm sure we'll have a proper
election
but he said that if we have a double dip
recession
there will be considerable pain and
suffering what do we think
you know what else jp morgan recently
said what
that square buying 50 million dollars
worth of bitcoin on the balance sheet
is a positive development
tell us about the double dip recession
why would that cause a lot of pain and
suffering
of course because there would be more
unemployment there would be more
businesses going out of business like it
would be bad
and uh if you remember we dropped then
the government stepped in and
what's the likelihood of the double dip
well if we have no more stimulus
that won't be good we'll be on the way
there uh it looks like
uh there is going to be more stimulus so
that's one prevention
two is if all of a sudden everything
continues to get shut down let's say
through the end of next year
that would be horrible because they
would have to keep printing more and
more
uh and you don't want them printing more
and more and i tend to think that we're
going to avoid a double dip recession
because they're gonna literally use
stimulus to get us over the hump
uh or over the dip but then what's gonna
happen is they're gonna make it worse
and in the future we're gonna have
something and it's gonna be even
is double is double dip recession
different than dead cat bounce you see
how i said dead cat and not fat cat
yes a double dip is it drops
then it starts to recover and then it
drops again but
the dead cat bounce is similar
a double dip recession though could be
the same uh
severity of drop so let's say it drops
30 in equities markets and then it does
it again 30 and it recovers all the way
back up and then
drops again 30 percent it's basically
just double dip happen twice
a dead cat bounces on the way down there
is
oh it looks like it's going back up it
recovers a little bit and then it slams
back down even further
got it we're you know we're just doing
shapes geometry trigonometry all kinds
of stuff squares recently announced
50 million dollar investment in bitcoin
is a strong vote of confidence for the
future of bitcoin
in a signal that the payments company
sees a lot of potential for the
cryptocurrency
as an asset jpmorgan analyst said in a
report dated tuesday
so what is jp morgan saying they
basically are saying that square
bought 50 million dollars put it on
their balance sheet
and that is incredibly bullish because
you have an
80 billion dollar public company doing
this
and they're not the first there's
obviously a lot of companies like galaxy
digital grayscale whatever
that they have bitcoin and they're
publicly traded now some of them don't
have it on their balance sheet
it's more like customer funds type stuff
or investments
but micro strategy was a 1.2 billion
dollar company run by michael saylor
he had 500 million dollars on his
balance sheet and he took 85
425 million and he put it into bitcoin
he left it on his balance sheet and then
he went out publicly and he was like
bitcoin is the hardest money in the
world i'm strapped ready protected let's
go
forward into this macro environment and
bitcoin's gonna
lead the way facts
fantastic bitcoin is leading the way get
yourself protected
business insider parent insider is
reportedly close to a deal to acquire a
controlling stake in morning brew
a new startup known for its popular
email newsletter on business
and finance so we know the guys at
morning brew they are our friends
we will not speak on this in i'm
speaking on it
no you're not why okay what do you know
i don't know anything that's why i'm
gonna speak about it this is all my
personal opinion i don't know
anything i talked to one person at
morningbrew i'm not gonna say who his
name is toby
and he literally told me nothing so what
i'm gonna end up saying here is two
things
one good for them if they do this uh
they think it's
good to get acquired at this point they
work their asses off they're gonna sell
a company for 75 million dollars
they started the company when they were
in college they raised very little money
about 750 000
and they built this thing they're going
to do 20 million dollars this year and
they didn't raise pretty much any
venture capital 750 000
from friends and family and it's growing
it's profitable
and they built a great business awesome
like first
check mark whether they sell it or not
awesome they're also great guys
facts two other they got like a little
bit of suspicious food
uh preferences but we won't get into it
yeah i don't think that they really are
excited about my domino's actions so you
know
we'll talk about that nobody's excited
about your dominoes action two
is uh this goes to show that the legacy
media brands they gotta start making
moves although i will argue business
insider is a very
forward forward-thinking brand they are
not
the traditional media company
maybe no they've been making smart
acquisitions in recent years
they have been hiring a lot of
interesting why don't they have more
subscribers then
what why don't they have more
subscribers i don't know
okay i'm sure they do i'm sure that it's
growing and it's going well
i'm just saying that more of these
legacy companies are gonna have to start
making these moves to get into
podcasts newsletters like all these new
mediums wait till
here here's my big takeaway from this
and alex and austin will laugh when i
when they hear me say this
this is the opening of the floodgates
for
traditional media companies are going to
start buying meme accounts facts
he's got a meme guy i do have a meme guy
but meme dealer i dm i'm on tour might
go give me a good meme and give them to
me and then i use them
but the whole idea is morning brew is
serious business news but they do it
in a very specific voice now they're not
doing
memes but what it does is it moves the
thing from like let's try to be the new
york times and be super serious and wear
our switching ties
to oh okay wait let's use a different
voice let's talk to the audience
differently
the next step in this is let's just hit
them with memes let's keep the eyeballs
and attention through memes gifs gifs
whatever you guys want to call
and if you're new to business uh morning
brew is a great way to get into it
because they use
very easy to understand language and
plain english
plain english what is it morningbrew.com
i think so yeah just just go to
morningbrew.com or just google morning
brew go sign up for their newsletter
send them a note and tell them that we
sent you also
my god all right what's next okay um
apple's 5g smartphone lineup is finally
here the company announced four new
iphones
the iphone 12 the iphone 12 pro 12 pro
max
and 12 iphone 12 mini
i i think i still have like the iphone
4. i don't think i've moved on from that
i don't like when they come out with new
iphones why
because they slow down the old ones
yeah you tweeted that they they slow
down the old ones
watch your phone's going to get slower
and it's going to hold less battery all
of a sudden
shocker i actually think that they
admitted they'd do this they did at one
point yeah they admitted it so this
isn't conspiracy theory land
like i always knew they did it because i
pay attention and i was like
they're messing with my phone to make me
buy the new one you always get the new
one like immediately no i don't know i
never update the software
i never update this no you like buy a
new phone oh the new phone no i
i i'm on the program where they just
give you it like uh
yeah but i don't have to pay for it i'll
pay for it
i'm on the renewal point yeah you pay
them more and then they give you a phone
no
no no no i don't think so all right well
and by the way the reason why i need a
new phone
i got to be taking good pictures from my
meme dealer so he could then write on it
and give me good memes
and i need a lot of computing power and
processing power you need to be taking
good pictures of me
yeah but any any camera could do that
you don't need a good camera to
make you look like uh let's go the next
time
okay um richard browning is a 41 year
old ceo of a company named
gravity this company gravity industries
is a jetpack startup trying to bring
jetpacks to the mainstream
he is also the company's main designer
and chief test pilot
since launching gravity three years ago
browning has taken off
thousands of times with his jet pack in
more than 30 countries
set a guinness world record twice and
accrued more than 10 million youtube
views for his exploits
but he still remembers his first liftoff
in 2016. he says we don't need jet packs
the slogan is we build
1 000 horsepower jet suits we don't need
jetpacks why not
can you imagine i can launch you off
right like me and my brothers when we
got our motorcycles and stuff
zooming around you're like that's
dangerous now imagine how we could fly
with jet packs all around oh
god i would i would send you off a
meeting that's why i'd be gone
oh i know i'd be gone where would you go
i would go to
uh over the hudson river and then come
back when i got hungry it's like a
little kid when i got hungry i'd come
back
former senate majority leader harry reid
is saying that the u.s government has
key evidence of possible close
encounters with ufos
and has been hiding it for years i don't
buy it if there were ufos trump would
have said it already there's no
they did they released it earlier this
year no that's not really what do you
mean it's not really apparently there's
a new documentary called the phenomenon
and the 80 year old politician i think
is in it
listen i'm telling you that ufos are
definitely a thing
there might not be aliens in the ufos or
maybe there is we don't know
but definitely ufos are real he claims
that there's more than one up there and
even believes they may have interfered
with american weapons
yeah he claims in the documentary that
they shut down all the missiles
no but i read the internet oh shocker
guys if you want to be smart go read the
internet
and he claims that they shut down a
bunch of the weapons like the missiles
in a base at one point and he said
something like if we wanted to shoot
missiles at that moment we couldn't have
done it
hmm i messing with no aliens yo aliens
if you guys are watching this
i'm a good guy i come in peace i come in
peace
yeah you you're shook you can't do that
with your hand i i
actually i couldn't do it for a long
time when i was little and then my
friend was like oh you can't do it and i
spent
literally all day practicing and then i
could do nerd
okay let's go you got a joke for us uh
this is our checkout instructions from
the airbnb
so but i do have one in my head okay
i renamed my iphone to titanic
do you know why do you want to know what
no because when you plug it into the
computer
it says the titanic is sinking
s-y-n-c-i-n-g
see deep meditative breaths
is equal to men and women boys and girls
men and women boys and girls i'm sorry
that you had to go through that it's
okay
traumatic experiences bring us closer
together and we will see you guys
tomorrow we're back
in new york tomorrow kitchen instant pot
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
black lives my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point percent interest on a
deposit in an interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends